how can you be Unapologetic
and non-negotiable
see so many of you want to play Big in
the world but you keep making it
optional and every time it gets too hard
you sit it back down the moment you make
it non-negotiable not an option slide
every option off the table you're not
wondering about the mountain and how big
it is because you said you must bow down
you have to have a level of certainty
for you you gotta believe in you bank on
you trust in you like you never have
before and every single thing that
you've ever done every single thought
you've ever had every single decision
you ever made built you for such a time
as this and you are perfect for the job